[Music]
all right thanks everyone for having me
my first time in Europe and in Berlin
husband is pretty awesome
so this talk I'm going to be talking
about my experiences with enchanting
novel and just a little intro for me my
twitter handle is left underscore pad
and I maintain bowel learner and a bunch
of other open source projects I really
like board games one of my favorites is
seven wonders and I haven't played the
battle expansion yet but I'm looking
forward to also like Korean barbeque
I took Sean Larkins of wet back to his
first time here in California and I'm
addicted to open source ditch this is
just I went to a restaurant in New York
City and I just reminded me of a the
github contribution graph so this talk
isn't going to be about wanting to get
people to contribute open source or
becoming a maintainer just to give you a
picture of what it's like to be a
maintainer maybe give some more
awareness what that's like so how did I
get started in open source I'm from
Atlanta Georgia and my first
introduction of resources through
hackathons you know the first project I
made with JavaScript was just manila
jaya if I didn't know about any
libraries or things like bootstrap or
angular eventually I learned how to use
NPM and download libraries like d3 I
might force pull requests to github was
to Khan Academy and I used this website
called first PR to figure out what it
was and I actually realized that it was
emerged because I didn't I was
rebase so you can see that I just have
all these commits there when I first
started working I met on this guy called
John Janu and he encouraged me to get
started in opens purse because I was
using anyway at the time I tried to
figure out how to get started I read all
the contributing docs I read all the
documentation again I went through all
the issues but I just it was really hard
for me to find a place to get started
I found that there was an issue about
updating the lynching consiglio it's
just updating some JSON so I went into
me to PR for that except I found out I
had to like learn how to use NPM shrink
wrap and like all this crazy stuff
eventually I ended up being like the
number 22 committed on a healer and that
was only because I updated the styling I
didn't do any core changes so all these
changes were mainly fix find me because
we didn't have auto fixing or pretty or
anything like that it was really cool
because I Gor was one of the maintain is
he even reached out emailed me and asked
if I wanted to get a t-shirt and then I
wanted to contribute more than Euler but
then I realized I had no idea what was
going on the codebase so I figured
because I was working all this styling I
should check out the project that I was
contributing to and so I found JSC s
which is a winter and that relief it was
really cool because they had Help Wanted
label and I was made it easy for me to
contribute so my first PR to this
project was just adding this table of
contents over time I ended up doing more
fixes like bug fixes and new rules and
eventually I got an email that said like
oh you can be on the core team which is
really awesome and even better than that
was few months before that I actually
got an email to work at the hands which
is where - the maintainer has worked out
so I moved to New York and right now I
work at the hands where I did JavaScript
and work on dable
so how did I become a maintainer um
basically Sebastian was saying that he
he was getting burned out and he wanted
to maintain bowel core and I found
different project aunt Dahlia sling and
I was working on winter so it made sense
like oh I can figure out how to
contribute to that and she wrote a blog
post a while back talking about his
problems with open source in the
community and happy getting burnt out
and so you know he started not working
on it and you know all these contributes
came in and I just happens to be one of
those people and yeah and then I feel
like I didn't even realize I was a
maintainer until he basically told me
like you know you slowly did more and
more stuff so it just kind of creeps up
on you and then realized they're like oh
why I'm going to now but the problem was
that I felt like I was a contributor the
whole time I was being a maintainer and
that led me to only doing the things
that I thought were easy so like I would
six docs or Nate fix bugs I would never
like look into the code and like figure
out how to make core changes and it's
funny because people are asking me all
these questions I didn't know the answer
either so I just have to like look it up
and then like sends a message really
okay this is what it is but then I guess
nobody knew that I should really know
what it was either yeah so then that led
need to think that the project wasn't
moving forward all we're doing is
maintaining what someone else already
created and I felt like at any point
that so that actually would come back
and tell me like what to do or like what
the vision of the project was and only
recently where it's like oh okay
we are the maintainer we should figure
out what the priorities are what the
roadmap is how to move forward and a lot
of that let's just thinking about like
why do we do open source in the first
place when you get really involved in
something whether it's work or open
source or anything else you know we
start
making that that's where we get our word
from and when it doesn't go well then we
start suffering we start thinking like
what are we working for words yeah so
this actually think that I've one thinks
that maintains know everything and they
have the answers to everything but we're
just other developers that you know
figure it out how to look it up so yeah
how do we actually measure success and
open source I think we reclaimed
glamorized like all the downloads we
have like a million dollars a month and
like all these stars and but then at the
same time like you know OSS wine like
everyone's using open source now but
what was the cost of that right we have
all these people that are volunteering
to you know spend their time working on
this thing for all these companies and
people that like will be actually
getting out of this so it's like we're I
think that it's not just like work that
we put in but like how we do it right
that I want to make sure that when we do
ask people to join open-source or become
any change that we figure out how to do
it sustainably gone so I'm just going to
talk about a few stories so github
issues a lot of people who use github
uses a lot of people switch off of
github issues we're probably the only
project that's switched and then went
back to github issues a while back
sebastian posted about how github was
not good you know use for managing
issues and so we moved to this thing
called fabricator and a lot of people
complained about it so some of the
positives there was a lot less back and
forth because you people had to like say
what bowel versions they are using the
input and output and so it was a lot
easier to actually reproduce issues it
also led to more people talking in PRS
because we had
disable the issues and they had a lot
more features like merging duplicates
and like reactions and all that stuff
but and it ended up being that there was
a lot more negatives all the previous
github links aren't available anymore so
if you had a blog post or any link to a
github issue just fail the issue tab is
gone so if you're like just coming to
this project for the first time your
language issues and that led to people
doing a lot of weird things like
emailing me directly or making a comment
in the commit of the of the repo or
making issues on the website repo rather
than the actual repo and also it let the
less issues which i think is like it
feels like it's good but I heard from a
lot of people that they didn't even want
to do it because they had no idea how to
use the interface and also over time it
github made a lot of improvements so
that it felt reasonable to move back so
we had to make more code to convert all
the issues to github it was insane I
didn't even do any of the work on this
Danya which is one of the team members
he had to write all this code that turns
people queries into github API calls and
make sure that it doesn't ping anybody
and all the yours redirects is the new
github URLs and so we made a bowel bot
and you can see that is imported 770
repos and it basically copy-pasted the
issue contents and when we finally did
this everybody was excited me too
because I felt like in the other
interface I started not looking at the
issues either stop caring all right more
frustration so intense packages so we
have bowel preset 2015 and I was like
well it's 2016 now so I guess I should
make a ballot 2016 and then I find out
that someone already made that but this
person was really nice and they said
there was their pleasure to was you know
give the package up to about
and then I just thought well what about
the next year right and then I go to and
I find out someone already made that -
but then the person didn't really want
to give up the name which actually kind
of hurts our project because it makes it
sound like the package they mate was
official and so that was like a long
back and forth and like a month later
they were able to get the project but
the real solution is to use what NPM has
now with scopes so that everything under
the abdominal would be official and then
we haven't done that yet but we're
looking - we're looking into it and then
the next thing would be that we should
just stop making preset ES 2020 xx
because then we'll have 100 config
values I mean it looks like people that
actually know what scope packages are
are willing to try it out okay so I
think some of you might have seen this
blog post and in the Jordan talks about
how Davao has this picture of Guy Fieri
and there's nothing you can do about it
right and it was fun and then James made
this PR that added this
I was kind of surprised at first but you
know went with it is feels cool and then
you get cool comments like this
which is really awesome to read and then
I send we see this March so I made this
and then all the way okay let's change
the color scheme and then I met Jordan
for the first time
[Music]
and then yeah so and then I was like
Jordan you should write an April Fool's
blog post for us to you can be like our
like chief marketing officer and he was
busy so I just made up this other thing
based on Wikipedia okay so I've been
talking a lot about open source and
where it's heading in that you know we
should make it sustainable so how do we
actually do that one way is by
contributing more contributors so what
we're doing on that front is trying to
focus more on like beginner-friendly
issues making like actually explaining
what you need to do not just being like
a if you note all these terminologies
and these words that you'll figure it
out
we're also participating in google
Summer of Code so we're going to have
two students start by working with us
and also rails girls Summer of Code and
we can also partner with a lot of other
organizations like schools or boot camps
our companies if you are copying that's
using da ville' then if you want to
sponsors let me know and yeah even a my
company is really awesome they're
letting me work fifty percent of time on
da ville' and the only reason why we
have creativity is because I was able to
work on it I work for two weeks
and we're also partnering with tc39
teetering on is the committee that works
on javascript and that was a good big
part of that right because we write with
all these like stage 0 plugins before
that's actually in the spec and the
reason why we can it's a good idea is
because then people would actually use
the syntax before we decide it's a good
idea and Logan was able to go to the lab
p39 meeting in March and I'm planning on
going in a we set up an open collective
and so what is the feature that will now
that I feel like I am I'm a trainer the
and we were working on an actual road
map we're trying to split up into teams
delegate and we're trying to partner
with a lot of different people so I
think once we figure it out like we have
a level of control we can do a lot of
awesome stuff so yeah look out for that
well seven thanks
[Applause]